Good morning, John. It's Thursday March 22nd.
I just mixed a misprinted
business card utilization idea with
putting stuff on my head. Now I have to
do is put a misprinted business card in
my pants and then put my pants on my
head. Mm-hmm. So I haven't forgot what I'm
gonna talk about today. Well first I have
to show you how I made this
misprinting business card utilization idea
and second I think I'm going to talk
about the continuation of the
Brotherhood 2.0 Book club.
A very long time ago, a commenter suggested
that I make a cube out of my misprinted
business cards and I thought he was kind
of crazy. But then I realized, all I
needed was a little magic. Ok actually he
sent me to a tutorial. You need six
business cards, you actually will
eventually need 12 but start with 6.
They'll be the exact same size which is
fine for me because I'll mine are the
same size. Then you take one and you bend
it over the other, you end up with these
little cups. You have to combine them
using a lot of manual dexterity.
This is half a cube. This is
when I get start to really hard on
camera because you have to hold
everything while you're doing it.
One more piece and the cube will be done.
Suddenly a surprisingly sturdy cube.
Now this is kind of ugly. What the tutorial
advises is that you use these flappy
things, here and here, and you use other
little cups that you've made, you slide
them into your flappy things like so.
Your face now becomes a flat pretty face
instead of these tabby ugly faces. So now
you just do that six times and you've
got this. This is a beautiful little eco
geek cube that I've used now
in my intros to my ego geek videos which
you will soon be able to see on ecogeek.org
Now everyone knows that I had to
read "We wish to inform you that tomorrow
we will be killed with our families". You
didn't have to read anything because the
book I'm injury was your book that you
were writing because you needed to
finish your book because you were past
your deadline. Plus all the people who
watch Brothehood 2.0 or John
Green fans and I think they would all
hate me if I stood between you and
finishing your book. So I've decided that
you should read world-changing, a user's
guide to the 21st century. Yes, it is this
big. Yes, I am kidding. I considered asking
you to read The God Delusion but I think
maybe that would be a little bit too
inflammatory. So instead, I'm asking you
to read Bill McKibben's new book "Deep
economy" because I run ecogeek. I'm
getting a free copy of "Deep economy" and
I will be reading it too because I'm
probably going to be interviewing the
author for my website and it'd be good
to know what the books about first and
I'd like to talk about it with you if
possible before the interview. Thank you
to everyone who's taken my plea to put
stuff on your head so seriously. I really
do believe that this is, at least in part,
an opportunity to decrease world suck.
I'd look like a Trojan. Hope you all
won't think I'm selfish when I say this
and it's great to see John with dumb
stuff on his head and I do like putting
stuff on my own head. But I kind of want
to see stuff on your head. So maybe we
could set something up, where people
send us pictures of stuff on their heads
and videos and videos of stuff on their
heads and people doing stuff while stuff
is on their heads. Yes, yes, I think this
is a good idea. Anyhow, I'll see you
tomorrow.